todo mundo encontra obstáculos pelo
caminho
quando você quer alcançar o objetivo é
esperado que obstáculos apareçam dizem
alguns que uma jornada sem obstáculos
não forma caráter
eu quero convidá-los agora a imaginar o
maior objetivo de cada um de vocês que
os desafios que vem à sua mente quando
você quer alcançar o sucesso
oi eu sou amiga guedes e esta onde eu
estou sentada é a julinha a julinha é
minha melhor amiga
ela é minha companheira de aventuras
eu ea chuvinha temos muitas histórias
para contar
vocês não escutam ela mais vil escuto e
eu vou passar pra vocês tudo que ela me
disser e ela me disse agora oi pessoal
no estávamos falando dos objetivos e
desafios da vida pra mim
independentemente dos meus objetivos
tudo é sempre muito trabalhoso
desde que eu me conheço por gente eu não
enxergo muito bem
aos 21 anos eu fui descobrir que eu não
jogava muito bem por causa de uma doença
a degeneração de stargardt nessa mesma
época eu terminava o curso de
publicidade e propaganda e eu corri
atrás de um grande sonho que era
trabalhar em uma grande empresa de
consumo nicação neutros sobre a cidade
e aí eu consegui eu consegui comecei a
morrer de medo porque se as pessoas
descobrissem que eu não enxergava o qq
agora venho falar de mim o que quero
cheguei a falar de mim aí o que eu fazia
eu pegava tudo que eu precisava saber
todo o conteúdo de tudo o que eu
precisava saber
corria banheiro me trancava eu sempre
tive uma memória muito boa e eu decorava
o voto diguinho com o papel coladinho
aqui no meu nariz e voltava pra minha
mesa como se nada tivesse acontecido
ah mas é difícil você esconder por muito
tempo das pessoas que você não enxerga e
o que vocês acham que aconteceu
quem foi a primeira pessoa que descobriu
que eu não enxergava a minha chefe e o
que vocês acham que ela fez comigo
ela me deu uma lupa gente efe o chefe
com essa lupa foram tudo de bom na minha
vida
a partir de então o perdimento de ser
quem era e me desenvolver
profissionalmente
assim como eu no mundo estima-se que
existem 1 bilhão de pessoas com as mais
diversas deficiências no brasil todos
somos em 45 milhões de pessoas com
deficiência gente são quatro vezes o
tamanho da cidade de são paulo
são 550 cinco vezes o tamanho da cidade
são sebastião da cidade que eu nasci no
interior de são paulo do b paulista
são três mil vezes o tamanho de tudo em
paulista
é muita gente e quando você olha mais
fundo esse número aí a coisa fica bem
mais séria mais da metade não tem
escolaridade
mais da metade não tem escolaridade e
por que esse número é tão alto assim
sabe
ao longo da minha trajetória
eu ganhei um outro brinde à esclerose
múltipla e hoje eu preciso da julinha eu
preciso de uma scooter para me locomover
você sabe que ficou mais fácil para o
interesse números é tão alto porque aí
eu me coloco no lugar de um jovem que
também usa uma cadeira de rodas e que
quer estudar e aí eu sei das
dificuldades que ele passa é muito
difícil mas ficou mais fácil para
entender esse número porque esse jovem
ao colocar a roda na porta de casa ele
já vai começar a encontrar várias
dificuldades
as calçadas que são esburacadas que são
irregulares que são estreitas
a maioria das pessoas com deficiência
ela está na classe social menos
favorecida então esse jovem vai precisar
de um transporte público para a imprensa
falar e ele vai do ponto de ônibus pegar
o ônibus
e olha que o ônibus passar o horário que
ele vai pra escola é um horário que os
ônibus vem lotado
aí ele não vai conseguir atrair o
motorista vira pra ele vai falar se pode
esperar o próximo
ele espera ele espera o próximo enquanto
o próximo chega a relatoria seguida ele
falasse olha a rampa está emperrada ou
então ele fala o elevador não está
funcionando e ele vai precisar contar
com os voluntários de dentro do ônibus
pra colocar o beijo do ônibus e quando
ele chegar no ponto de ônibus dele
descer no medo do ônibus teve poder para
a escola nisso ele já chegou atrasado na
escola
aí quando ele chega do prédio da escola
escola não tem rampa
a escola não tem banheiro adaptado na
sala de aula não tenho uma mesa para ele
encaixar a cadeira de roda para ele
poder estudar adequadamente é o tempo
inteiro precisando de ajuda
gente isso fica mais fácil para a gente
entender porquê de tantas pessoas com
deficiência não serem alfabetizadas
por quê
eficiência dessas pessoas
ela é tratada e é vista a deficiência
como um problema e na verdade essas
pessoas elas têm uma condição que é
jogada nas costas dela e da família
delas como uma deficiência como sendo um
problema e um problema que elas mesmas
têm que resolver
tem que se virar para resolver falei pro
tela
isso é uma escada ou gente agora olhem
pra mim
qual a utilidade que ela tem na minha
vida
essa escada quando ela não vem
acompanhada de uma rampa é como se ela
me chamar se o tempo todo diz deficiente
é essa a utilidade dela ela me lembra o
tempo inteiro que eu preciso de ajuda
se existem tantas pessoas como eu no
mundo a escada ainda continua sendo a
única opção porque tem tantos
restaurantes que não tem cardápio em
braile por exemplo porque as pessoas que
fazem isso não vê isso não enxergam por
esse ângulo o olhar dessas pessoas é
deficiente
elas não nos enxergam como alunos de
suas escolas como funcionários de suas
empresas
elas não nos enxergam como consumidores
de seus estabelecimentos
elas não nos enxergam como cidadãos de
seu país e esse mesmo olhar deficiente
não vê que o brasil possui 45 milhões de
pessoas que querem estudar que querem
trabalhar que querem ganhar dinheiro que
querem consumir
que querem girar a economia porque uma
comunidade que se une para tornar o seu
bairro mais acessível um pequeno
estabelecimento pequeno negócio coloca
uma rampa ou informações em braile por
exemplo nos aproxima da sociedade o que
além de justo a beneficia
financeiramente
afinal de contas nós queremos comer
comprar roupa sair passear viajar uma
vez eu ea julinha
nós fomos pro chicago o leu e ela aí
gente olha ai que felicidade olha que
cara boa então chicago é uma cidade
totalmente acessível é uma cidade onde
todas as pessoas com deficiência o tempo
inteiro na rua andando pra lá pra cá e
do trabalhar indo para a escola ainda
passear
chicago é uma cidade que te convida pra
ir pra rua
é uma delícia você tem uma vida
completamente independente lá lá ninguém
é deficiente
daí ela
poxa milan mas você acha que a
infraestrutura das cidades brasileiras
um dia passar a ser igual ao de chicago
por exemplo a resposta para isso eu não
tenho mas está em um lugar onde a
sensação é você conviver com essa
sensação com essa igualdade onde ninguém
se vê diferente de ninguém por causa de
uma condição onde você não é lembrado o
tempo inteiro de seus limites
a gente é um sonho é um sonho que eu
luto e vivo para trazer essa realidade
para o nosso país porque a minha
condição não é reversível mas a condição
de todo e qualquer acesso é muito
obrigada